a government that's big enough to give
you everything you want is big enough to
take away everything you've got hi I'm
Matt Welch editor-in-chief of Reason
magazine and I'm joined today by
Lawrence Reed the president of the
foundation for economic education which
is widely considered to be the
first-ever of sort of think-tank devoted
to issues of Liberty that's correct
can you tell us a little bit for people
who aren't really aware of fie and its
history how it started what what it's
been over the years fie was started in
1946 by the late Leonard Reed no
relation he spelled his name re ad but a
well-known man throughout the
free-market movement he was a leader in
the spread of ideas and he felt very
strongly in the late 40s that ideas of
Liberty were not being given a very very
good hearing and that there needed to be
a scholarly place that would produce
publications and programs would educate
people about the both economics and the
morality of the free and civil society
and over the years how's the
organization involved what is it
primarily focusing on in 2009 for most
of our history we have published that
have been best known for a journal
called the Freeman and we continue to
publish that and it goes to subscribers
all over the world we also hold seminars
for high school and college students and
this summer we will double the number of
our previous all-time record so we're on
the move Wow so you're involved with
economic education I imagine that in the
year 2009 that's kind of a interesting
bittersweet type of thing to be doing do
you feel like you're rehashing the same
arguments that were made or maybe even
thought to have been won and in the past
now with a current yes to a great extent
we are reviving old ideas and and we're
bringing to bear and current issues
concepts and and contributions of great
thinkers that go back quite a number of
years but people have to constantly
learn and relearn these lessons fees
unique
sense that we not only focus on economic
education but also the moral foundations
of a free society so we talk a lot about
the importance of things like character
and other virtues required I think to
succeed in a free society if you had to
name you know maybe three lessons that
are being forgotten or that need to be
re learned in 2009 involving economics
what would they be well one would be
that government has nothing to give
anybody except what it first takes from
somebody another one I think would be a
government that's big enough to give you
everything you want is big enough to
take away everything you've got and then
another one is that free people are not
equal economically they will generate
differences in income because we're
different one person to another
and equal people economically are not
free how did you first be get involved
like when and how in sort of
libertarianism or classical liberalism I
first got involved in 1968 at the age of
fourteen oh wow when I was captivated by
events in Czechoslovakia spring notice
Prague Spring as there were freedoms
blossoming in that country and the great
focus in the world was on the question
will the Soviets allow the the Czechs to
do their thing and so I watched that
very carefully and then in August of 68
the Soviets invaded and within a few
days I saw an ad for a demonstration at
Pittsburgh put on by a group called
young Americans for freedom to protest
the invasion so I at age 14 bought a bus
ticket rode up the Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania we burned a Soviet flag and
I let the world know that we didn't like
what they did so but that was the
beginning that's how I first got then
connected with the Freeman with Reason
magazine and other people and
publications in the movement and you
were one of the first or original
subscribers Teresa
oh I remember very well the original and
labels were hand addressed by now maybe
by Bob Poole himself
I don't know way back when in 68 69 I
when I was getting in looking at the
climate right now what would you say for
or is your biggest sort of fear about
what might happen or is transpiring and
what's your biggest hope for things
going in the right direction
my biggest fear at the moment is that
Americans in the search for short-term
security the feeling that well we got to
do something for now we'll sacrifice
some critically important and eternal
values of liberty and limited government
and not get anything to show for it not
even in a way of security that's my
biggest fear my hope is that we can turn
things around and and and show the
American people that the crisis that
we're now in is not the fault of freedom
and free markets but just the opposite
that this is a phenomenal learning
opportunity here to realize once and for
all that government in charge of the
economy is a prescription for disaster
that's great on that note I'm Matt Welch
for recent TV and thank you